la ilusión por la llegada de las vacunas
a perú duró poco tras que el presidente
interino francisco sagasti anunciara el
domingo que un total de 487 personas
entre ellas funcionarios públicos se
vacunaron en secreto aprovechando una
partida complementaria de scinopharm el
mandatario condenó los hechos y aseguró
que los responsables serán investigados
y apartados del ejecutivo por nuestra
parte desde el ejecutivo separaremos a
todas las personas involucradas en este
lamentable suceso en personas que no son
capaces de cumplir cabalmente su deber
como servidores públicos no tienen
cabida en este gobierno el escándalo
comenzó el jueves cuando se destapó que
el expresidente martín vizcarra había
recibido la vacuna en octubre vizcarra
aseguró que había sido voluntario de un
ensayo clínico aunque la fiscalía y la
población tienen dudas al respecto la
controversia también llegó hasta el
actual gobierno de sagasti con figuras
como el ex ministra de exteriores
elizabeth act quien renunció tras
reconocer haber sido vacunada y la ex
ministra de salud pilar mazzetti
involucradas en la
que presento sagasti también figuran los
nombres de otros cargos públicos el caso
conocido como vacuna que llega en plena
segunda ola de la pandemia haya causado
indignación entre los peruanos es un
tema creo que más ético no no no puedes
tú inocular te y tu familia y algunos
pocos funcionarios cuando hay gente en
la primera línea este doctor es que se
ha muerto no
sagasti y nombró a allan wagner como un
nuevo ministro de exteriores en un
intento por recomponer su gabinete
mientras los peruanos se enfrentan a una
crisis de confianza política a la par
que la pandemia y de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de abril